YO, STRAIGHT UP,
LET'S GET DRUNK, BABY.
- OKAY.
YO, THAT TINY PROFESSOR
WAS RIGHT.
HOW AM I GONNA BE A DAD
IF I DON'T EVEN KNOW MY OWN?
AND THERE WAS ONLY ONE PERSON
WHO KNEW WHO HE WAS.
I FOUND MY MOMMY
IN A HALFWAY HOUSE,
BUT HER ANSWER WAS NOT
AS SIMPLE AS I HAD HOPED.
- YOU GOT A GIRL PREGNANT.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN
BRING A GIRL OVER
FOR YOUR MOTHER
TO MEET THE GIRL BEFORE
YOU GET HER KNOCKED UP?
- I'M NOT ALLOWED TO SEE HER.
IT'S PART OF THE SHOW.
IT'S PART OF--
THAT'S WHAT'S DAD ACADEMY.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE IS TO--
- OH, THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S GOOD.
LET THE DADS GET
THEIR OWN SHOW.
I HAD TO TAKE CARE OF YOU
ALL BY MYSELF,
AND IT WAS THE GREATEST MOMENT
OF MY LIFE, MY BOY.
I'M LIVING IN A HALFWAY HOUSE.
I'M DOING GREAT.
- I WISH I COULD JUST
STAY HERE WITH YOU.
I DON'T WANT TO
GO BACK OUT THERE.
BUT DAD ACADEMY
SAYS I GOT TO FIND MY DADDY.
- I COULD HELP YOU.
- REALLY?
- YEAH, LET'S TALK ABOUT IT,
BUT I THINK WE SHOULD
GET OUT OF HERE.
- BUT AREN'T WE--ARE YOU
ALLOWED TO LEAVE HERE?
- FORTUNATELY,
C-CZAR IS VERY DISTRACTIBLE.
THIS IS MY PLACE, OKAY?
- REALLY?
- I OWN THIS HALFWAY HOUSE.
MAMA IS DOING GOOD.
- MAMA'S A BALLER, HUH?
- C-CZAR CAME AT A REALLY
GOOD TIME FOR ME.
OKAY, WATCH THE DOOR, AND MAMA'S
GONNA GO OUT THE WINDOW.
- WAIT, WHY ARE YOU
GOING OUT THE WINDOW?
HOLY CRAP,
WE'RE STRAIGHT-UP VILLAINS.
[exciting music]
YO, WE OUTSIDE.
LIKE, TELL ME WHO MY DAD IS NOW.
- THERE WERE A LOT OF MEN,
C-CZAR.
I DON'T KNOW
WHO YOUR DADDY IS.
- WELL, WHAT ABOUT
YOUR PATIENTS, MOM?
- I AM A PATIENT, YOU IDIOT.
OH, MY GOD.
BABY, MAMA'S GOT TO FLY.
DO WHATEVER YOU GOT TO DO.
FIND HIM, C-CZAR.
- BLAP, BLAP, BLAP, BLAP!
I'M THE ONLY VILLAIN
IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD!
MOM, I'M COMING FOR YOU.
I JUST CAN'T RUN FAST
'CAUSE MY PANTS ARE SO LOW.
- PULL THEM UP, BABY!
I'M SORRY I LIE A LITTLE.
- IT WAS DISAPPOINTING
NOT TO KNOW WHO MY DAD WAS,
BUT IT WAS GREAT
TO RECONNECT WITH MY MOM.
AND THAT MEANT IT WAS TIME
FOR ANOTHER SWEET TATTOO.
THE PRODUCER SAID
THAT THIS TATTOO SAYS,
"SORT OF COMING TO
TERMS WITH MY DAD,"
WHICH I ALMOST DID.
I STILL CAN'T READ.